Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Japanese short film called “The beauty
tax.” Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in a Japanese office where the
manager yells at everyone for not being good
enough at their jobs. However, when a beautiful
woman, Aiko makes a mistake, he lets her off
the hook and even apologizes for being rude.
Aiko’s coworkers are not very fond of her because
no matter how hard they work, the manager only
favors Aiko. Not just at work, but wherever they
go, people give Aiko extra attention. At lunch,
only she gets a complimentary pudding,
while returning home from work,
a salesman gives her two packets of free products,
while the others get one packet per two people.
For Aiko, it is a normal day because she
is used to getting special treatment.
Somewhere else in a press conference, the
prime minister announces that the financial
condition of the country is in a complicated
situation. Hence, to cope with this problem,
the government has decided to enforce a new law
in which the attractive women of the country will
have to pay a beauty tax. The protestors in the
audience claim that this is modern-day systemic
discrimination against women but the prime
minister claps back, saying that beautiful
women receive a lot of financial privileges which
is not fair for ugly people. He declares that the
law will soon be enforced and the ones who try
to avoid the beauty tax will be punished.
Some days later, Aiko is approached by a
man who offers her a modeling job for a
beauty salon. Her colleagues, jealous of her
popularity, walk away. As Aiko follows them,
the camera pans towards a newspaper headline
that says the beauty tax has been enacted.
When the three go for lunch that day, Aiko’s
coworkers pay a thousand yen for their food;
however, Aiko is asked to stand in front of
a scanning device. The device is supposed to
scan women and measure what percentage of tax they
should pay, according to their beauty. Aiko poses
for the machine and it scans her face. The results
say that she is the second level of beauty,
so she should pay 20% beauty tax. Her total
comes out to twelve hundred yen which she
reluctantly pays. The restaurant that used to
provide her with free complimentary desserts
is now making her pay extra just because she is
beautiful. Later while buying a bottle of water,
Aiko again has to pay more than a normal person.
Likewise, all the pretty girls of the nation,
according to the level of their attractiveness,
have to pay a certain amount of tax.
The news reporters interview common people about
their thoughts on the tax enactment and people
seem to be quite happy about it. One man claims
that he has spent a lot of money on pretty girls
so it is only fair if they have to pay more taxes
than him. Another not-so-pretty girl states that
the beautiful ones were getting pampered, so it is
only appropriate if they have to pay more. Before
the law was enacted, many people thought of it
as discrimination towards women but after it
was enforced, the people have changed sides. Now,
most of the nation is in favor of the beauty tax.
The next day, Aiko receives her paycheck and
excitedly opens it, only to be disappointed. The
money on the check is a lot less than her actual
salary. She goes to the manager with the concern
and finds out that the beauty tax also applies to
her salary which means she will get twenty percent
less than what she used to. The manager calmly
explains to her that it is not his fault but the
government’s. To make her feel better, he offers
to treat her with meals wherever he can.
Enraged by the discrimination, Aiko and other
beautiful women of the city, hold up signs and
protest at the tax enforcement office. The man
there asks them to go away because the decision
has been made, and it is definite. Aiko retaliates
that this is the worse form of discrimination but
the man claps back claiming that they have had
the pretty privilege. He asks Aiko to give it a
thought and dismisses the matter. When Aiko thinks
about it, she slowly begins to realize she has
had pretty privilege all her life. She remembers
when she was little, she broke a flower pot once.
The adults used to get mad at the children for
doing the same thing but their reaction was
different for her. In college, her friends didn’t
let her pay for meals any time they went out, just
because of her beauty. And even now, at work, her
boss pardons all her mistakes but he gets annoyed
when others do the same. Back in the present,
the officer states that beautiful girls like her
have always had social and economical benefits
which are unfair to others, hence, the beauty
tax is a reasonable law that ensures fairness.
To make Aiko feel better, he adds that her beauty
has been recognized throughout the country
by the standards set by the government.
Looking at the situation from a different
perspective, Aiko starts to feel better
about the twenty percent tax. The narrative
changes when the girls who pay higher taxes
start to be seen as the better ones in society.
Aiko even goes to a reality television show and
expresses her happiness at being one of the
few people who pay twenty percent beauty tax.
The girls say that they are being asked out often
at restaurants and bars when guys find out that
they pay beauty tax. Even at Aiko’s work, her
popularity skyrockets and she starts being known
as the girl who pays twenty percent beauty tax.
Unlike her previous interaction with restaurant
cashiers, now Aiko is delighted to pay more money
for being beautiful. Her manager calls her when he
has important business meetings and his business
partner signs the papers without hesitation after
seeing Aiko’s beautiful face. While purchasing
things, she makes sure to emphasize that she pays
a twenty percent tax to those around her who only
pay five percent. When Aiko receives her paycheck,
instead of getting mad, she is flattered and
considers it the fate of a beautiful woman.
She is thriving more than ever until
Raiko Tajima arrives at her office.
Raiko pays twenty-five percent beauty tax
making her more beautiful than Aiko by law.
Her colleagues all follow Raiko around claiming
that she is prettier than any celebrity they have
seen. Aiko is stung by jealousy to see all the men
drool over Raiko because she is used to being the
center of attention. She vows to be prettier than
Raiko in some days. Then, she starts to exercise
day and night in hopes of losing weight. She
also goes to the spas daily and receives several
expensive facial treatments. After a lot of hard
work, she goes to a restaurant and scans herself
to find out that she now has to pay thirty percent
tax. Aiko jumps in happiness to have finally
gotten prettier than Raiko. But when she looks
at her bank balance, her happiness vanishes to
see only two yen left. Her day gets worse when she
hears about Raiko’s plastic surgery. At first, she
believes Raiko might have gotten plastic surgery
to be prettier but is shocked when she gets a
look at her face. Tired of being charged more for
everything, Raiko had surgery and turned ugly. She
looks completely different than she used to.
It turns out that her fiance left her because she
was too expensive to take care of. As Aiko thinks
that her day couldn’t get worse, she is summoned
by her manager who informs her that she has been
fired. It turns out that the company had to pay
more taxes for every beautiful employee and
to cut the unnecessary expenditure, they have
decided to fire all the beautiful people. Soon,
the narrative around the beauty tax changes again.
Beauty products to make women seem uglier start
selling out. The people who were proud to pay more
because of their beauty start making themselves
seem uglier to keep their jobs. Moreover, men
start to avoid beautiful women because their cost
of living is too high. One day, Aiko is in the bar
distressed about her life. A man approaches her
and offers help to get her taxes low. Before she
can continue the conversation, Aiko gets a call
from their family lawyer. It turns out that her
dead mother has left her with a lot of wealth that
she inherited from her uncle. However, the beauty
tax also applies to inheritances. Since Aiko’s
mother was also very beautiful, the inheritance
amounts to negative one million yen, meaning that
if Aikp wants to claim the inheritance, she will
have to pay the government and receive nothing.
At night, Aiko goes to the bar again and meets the
same guy. He introduces himself as Nonomura.
Aiko and Nonomura get closer while talking.
He suggests she make herself look ugly to avoid
taxes and even hands her fake thick eyebrows.
Aiko is a little skeptical because avoiding paying
taxes might get her in jail but Nonomura assures
her many girls do the same. The next day, Aiko
draws thick lashes and freckles over her face.
She also hides her beautiful hair with a short
wig and adds a huge mole to her nose. The tax
officer is startled to see her come in. She claims
that she has been stressed because of her mother’s
death and has gained some weight. The officer
scans her and the machine declares her ugly.
He finally takes Aiko off the pretty women list
which means she will no longer have to pay for the
inheritance tax. Thinking that all her problems
are solved, she rushes outside and calls Nonomura.
He congratulates her and invites her to meet his
parents in a nice dress. Aiko understands that the
man is interested in her and smiles to herself.
She is happy that even in a time like this,
someone is in need of her beauty.
On the day they are supposed to go out,
Aiko excitedly does her makeup. However, her plans
go in vain when two policemen knock on her door
and arrest her for trying to be ugly to
avoid paying taxes. They also inform her
that Nonomura is a notorious marriage swindler
who covets the inheritance of beautiful women.
It turns out that he was never interested in her
beauty and was only trying to get her inheritance.
Aiko is then sentenced to two years in prison.
She is depressed and alone as her life has taken a
turn for the worse. Her only friend in the prison
is her cellmate who is also in for trying to be
ugly and avoid taxes. As they talk, Aiko wishes
that she was born ugly. If only her nose was one
centimeter short, her life might have turned
out different. But her cellmate advises her to
never turn away from reality. She claims that they
both are unhappy right now because of their dull
hearts, not because of their beauty. According to
her, they were too focused on having a pretty face
that they forgot to keep their heart happy.
Aiko is inspired by her friend’s words.
She vows to work on beautifying her heart when she
gets out. Cut to two years later, Aiko is finally
let out of prison. She is dedicated to working
on her heart this time. She sees a kid crying for
ice cream and kindly offers to buy one for her.
However, the shopkeeper returns her extra money
saying that she isn’t pretty enough for beauty
tax. Moreover, some kids from behind her call
her ugly. Hearing this, the “beautification of
heart” leaves Aiko’s mind. She gets offended
claiming that she is still very beautiful. But it
turns out that in the last two years the standard
of beauty has changed completely. Since men
favored ugly women because of the beauty tax,
they became more popular and now are considered
more beautiful than traditionally beautiful women.
Amazed at the new world, Aiko hands the
kid her ice cream but she refuses to accept
it because of Aiko’s ugliness.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.